hi i'm alicia and today i'm going to
discuss
who citizen developers are and why
they're able to digitally transform
their work with appsheet
let's get started
the demand for citizen developers is on
the rise with an estimated 2 billion
people who can benefit from this skill
set
but what exactly is a citizen developer
in short they are the people closest to
the problem who've been empowered to
find or create a solution
in order for these individuals to be
empowered they need access to technology
that is democratized in nature
while preventing the use of non-i.t
sanctioned third-party platforms
also known as shadow it google cloud's
no code platform app sheet provides
just that it allows anyone the access
and ability to create applications
within the framework provided by their
itt
let's walk through a quick example meet
annie an operational lead for a
manufacturing company
annie has been receiving feedback that
the current inspection practice
is inefficient and impacting the
customer experience
workers want a mobile solution but her
it team doesn't have the time to build
an application
she needs something custom and she needs
to find it quickly
annie discovers app sheet a no code
platform that can help her create an
application in days or weeks
rather than months or years when working
with the platform she discovers that
there are governance capabilities
and she's able to work with her i.t team
to put the right policies in place
that can prevent shadow i.t she builds
an app within this framework and
shares it with her colleagues on the
manufacturing floor iterating with
feedback
until she's built the right solution for
the need
not only has annie helped her team but
she's obtained the valuable skill set of
building apps with no code
this means that in addition to being an
operations lead she can now count
herself among the growing group of
citizen developers
other departments soon take notice of
how quickly annie was able to solve the
problem with no code
since it has already provided governance
guidelines
other teams are able to start leveraging
appsheet becoming citizen developers
themselves
and it's not just operations leads who
benefit from citizen development
accountants teachers i.t professionals
and more have all enlisted no code
technology to digitally transform their
work
with custom line of business solutions
like annie's
ready to start your citizen developer
journey get started today by clicking
the link in the description below
happy app building